[Música]
a escala en parís
aída palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y de france
24 hoy nos vamos a ir a los años 90 a
eeuu sobre toda la zona de seattle para
hablarles de unas mujeres que
revolucionaron el mundo del punk y con
esa revolución también contribuyeron a
la evolución del feminismo y lo hacemos
con la periodista francesa mathilde
cartoon matilde muchísimas gracias por
estar con nosotros un placer bueno acaba
de publicar este libro riot girl
revolution style now en la editorial lo
hemos de guest y es un libro que habla
de esa revuelta de unas chicas quienes
eran las riders fueron estudiantes
tenían 20 años y a ella le encantaba el
rock el rock a este momento de la
historia
era algo muy poco muy ones y entonces
ellas noticieron que durante los
conciertos nunca había sitio para las
mujeres siempre había mucha violencia y
ellas siempre estaban como en el papel
de la cookie el papel que siempre como
un objeto y nunca como un sujeto y ellas
querían tomar haber tocar los
instrumentos ir en el escenario y bueno
ser como músicas y existir por su misma
y no sólo como un objeto sexual
si hay una frase que en el libro que
dice bueno no no hemos venido a salir
con los chicos con el grupo nosotras
somos el grupo es un poco más radical
bueno son punk entonces dicen a ver yo
estoy aquí para con el grupo yo
soy el grupo y esto me parece esencia
así es como un resumen desde de esa
revolución y bueno antes de entrar a
explorar este mundo tan interesante me
gustaría que me explicara por qué se
interesó por él no se interesó por
quieres decir por el movimiento usted
ponga se interesa por las por la radio
del saber es que yo soy súper animada
por lo derroquen grohl y también soy muy
interesada por el feminismo y de
estudiante tenía que hacer una tesis y
yo quería haber mezclar política y
también rock y para mí el mejor ejemplo
son las radios porque ella hicieron un
corriente musical que también fue un
movimiento social tuvieron como un
manifesto política habían reglas muy
claras para crear un escenario haber un
espacio de empoderamiento para las
mujeres y me parecía completamente
fenomenal esta revolución
porque el pan que era el terreno de
juego perfecto para para la riot girls y
explíqueme esas reglas porque bueno pues
el punk es una música que surgió en los
años 70 en contra a todo el orden
establecido y entonces lo el punk
era que tú no necesitas conocer sus
instrumentos perfectamente solo hay que
tocarle solo hay que exprimir te no no
hace falta ser un virtuoso de música eso
para nada solo hay que tu propia
energía y decir lo que tú tienes en las
tripas
entonces fue un como se dice un
corriente musical muy interesante para
las personas que se sentían dejadas de
lado no todos entonces hay un espacio
para hablar de racismo de sexismo y de
todas las cosas que de todas las
discriminaciones que existen en la
sociedad pero así entonces para ellas
fue enorme porque hay algo de la
filosofía de hazlo tú mismo no witch of
self es algo muy interesante para ellas
y entonces lo cogieron y desarrollaron
su propio sus propias ideas en esta
escena en este espacio artístico y por
ejemplo que reglas imponían e impone a
ver los hay otros cuando hicieron su
propia escena lo hicieron sin los
hombres había algo de por qué los
hombres siempre los hombres o quiero
decir una mirada exterior siempre te
critica y siempre te te pone un papel te
pone una etiqueta
en momentos de que tú solo necesitas que
desarrollar y descubrir lo que te gusta
y descubrir tu voz y entonces por
ejemplo hacerlo entre sí misma era muy
importante para no estar perdida en la
mirada y en la en el sin que te juzguen
exactamente como se lo toman los hombres
esta entrada fue el pan de las mujeres
como siempre no porque a ver es que
imagínate además que era como 30 años
antes ya sabemos que ahora no es tan
fácil decir algo de mujeres a los
hombres pero imagínate 30 años antes y
entonces cuando ellas por ejemplo un
grupo de los más importantes de este
movimiento se llama bikini kirk y cuando
bikini kill entra en el escenario
siempre dicen oye las chicas al frente y
los chicos detrás ya ellos no le gustaba
mucho este tipo de geografía en la fosa
no era algo muy entonces había mucha
resistencia de la parte de los hombres
muchas también amenazas amenazas de
muerte hubo muchas agresiones también
bueno fue muy difícil
muy violento inferior bueno pues sí le
parece vamos a ver a escuchar uno de
esos conciertos de bikini kill con la
cantante
carlin gana al frente sí
[Música]
con el que de qué hablan la radio terso
o bikini kill porque es un movimiento
calidades o feminismo pan política de
qué hablan las canciones hablan de la
realidad de ser mujer y en los años 90
en eeuu la tu realidad es
trata mucho de agresiones sexuales trata
de violaciones trata de una realidad muy
concreta que se está durante un momento
de la política americana donde sólo se
trataba de posts feminismo como si el
feminismo no era no era importante a
este momento como si ya las mujeres
tienen derechos y además y se han
superado ya no exactamente pero bueno la
realidad es que no porque a ver
dentro de un japón dentro de una
relación quiero decir el uniforme si
perdona un informe del fbi aid hicieron
que en el 91 había una mujer sobre
cuatro americana que va a ser víctima o
ha sido víctima de una violación esto me
parece enorme en un país así además que
el fbi no es conocido como
algo muy progresista está un poco así
que si os lo dice en el número me parece
enorme
justamente carlin gana a la cantante de
bikini kill es muy importante para este
movimiento y tiene una historia
particular familiar porque su madre
también jugó un rol esencial en el
aprendizaje del feminismo
de hecho aprenden casi juntas el
feminismo y también jugará un rol muy
importante la universidad de evergreen
en el estado de washington
explíquenos un poco la historia de
carling por qué fue tan importante ese
aprendizaje del feminismo esa historia
familiar la de su madre a ver es que
ella ellos vienen de la clase media
americana muy clásica no hay nada que
decir
no hay nada particular el padre fue
era alcohólico era tuvo muchos
comportamientos muy border no de
agresiones sexuales pero siempre o en el
límite super límite sí y la madre
entonces no decía nada no había
resistencia adentro de la casa pero ella
cada domingo iba a la iglesia y en la
iglesia había una asociación que iba a
ayudar a las mujeres maltratadas
entonces fue como una resistencia
clandestina la madre siempre iba y bueno
y hablando con estas mujeres le pusieron
ideas quiero decir le pusieron una
curiosidad para entender por qué estas
cosas suelen pasar porque los hijos
también son víctimas de este tipo de
violencias y entonces ella
leyó muchos libros muchas teorías
feminista y un momento tuvo como una
epifanía como de eso no puede ser y
entonces dejó el marido y fui fue y se
fue de manifestaciones de protesta
ciones feminista con cut link de pequeña
averno
gloria steinem por ejemplo que es una
figura muy importante del feminismo
americano y que cada quien se acuerda de
este primer momento como algo muy
especial porque por la primera vez
estaba
alrededor de mujeres y sólo mujeres
hablando con animación con ánimo con
mucha mucho amor también de lo mejor que
puede pasar si sólo nos juntamos había
algo muy fuerte en esta solidaridad me
gustaría que me explicara brevemente la
conexión entre carlin hannah y kurt
cobain de nirvana si a ver es que en
olimpia que es la capital del estado de
washington como a una hora de seattle es
que es súper pequeño y además cada uno
toca música con cada uno y kurt cobain
es de esta parte y entonces él
es que el tocaba con tubey bale que es
una de una música de vic y nikhil
también y bueno y salieron un poco
juntos bueno tiene 20 años y fue to be
la que le aprendí a él lo que es el
feminismo lo que es lo que hay que hacer
no la lucha que lo que tenemos que hacer
y entonces el completamente esposo la
causa y cuando nirvana fue enormísimo
cada vez en cada entrevista siempre
hablaba de sus amigas de las raids y
bendiciendo que hay que poner un poco de
luz en este tema que es muy importante
para que todo cambie que la sociedad
cambia también y cuál ha sido la huella
de la radio del sí porque un grupo tan
confidencial finalmente de los años 90
usted cree que ha tenido tanto impacto
en otros grupos otras cantantes más
tarde porque ya se hicieron esta
revolución quiero decir que se quedaron
en él como eran un movimiento muy
radical feminista anticapitalista y
ellas no querían ni hablar con los
medios grandes
pero sus ideas de revolución
si se murieron en la cultura popular
americana porque a ver es que de la
misma manera que madonna por ejemplo fue
a buscar por cosas nuevas por por ideas
nuevas en el underground en la llave del
subterráneo y ella encontró como el
booking por ejemplo pues los sellos
discográficos a este momento también
buscaron algo nuevo ideas nuevas y
encontraron a toda esta angustia toda
esta rabia hay algo muy salvaje no y lo
cogieron este espíritu y lo pusieron en
nuevos artistas por ejemplo alanis
morissette que alanis morissette que su
álbum que se llama jack del tom cruise
fue vendido a 30 millones de discos en
todo el mundo fue absolutamente enorme y
la primera vez que su primera portada de
rolling stones de américa no había
escrito en white email la mujer blanca
enfadada así que este arquetipo nació en
el hondo haga nación con las riders y
después fue destacado por el mainstream
y esta idea bueno la cantamos todos en
nuestros coches y todo no es algo que es
que fue cogido de este tema y que ahora
está puesto así
bueno pues muchísimas gracias matilde
cartoon autora del libro rayo girl por
haber estado con nosotros con esta
historia apasionante muchas gracias y
muchísimas gracias a todos ustedes por
habernos acompañado y a florencia valdés
por haber coordinado este programa ya
saben que nos pueden seguir por internet
en rf y mundo.com y en france24 punto
com hasta pronto amigos
[Música]